تحدثنا بالامس في العربيه 360 عن حرب
المسيرات او الحرب التي تقترب من حدود
روسيا سلاح يبرز يوما بعد يوم ويثبت توجه
متزايدا لاستخدامه من طرفي النزاع الرئيس
الاوكراني كشف معلومات عن خطه روسيه لحمله
طويله تشنها المسيرات هدفها استنزاف
اوكرانيا وقال انه تلقى تقارير
استخباراتيه تشير الى ان موسكو ستشن
الهجمات باستخدام طائرات شاهد ايرانيه
الصنع ويبدو ان غارات مسيرات الروسيه على
اوكرانيا يزدادت بشكل الملحوظ اذ شنت
موسكو هجمات على المدن على محطات الطاقه
في جميع انحاء البلاد خاصه خلال الليالي
الثلاثه الماضيه لكن نزلتك اكد على وجوب
ضمان ان يفشل من اسمائهم الارهابيين
بتحقيق اهدافهم خصوصا بعد ما تصدت
الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه ودمرت عشرات
الطائرات الروسيه ايرانيه الصبح
من معايا
باستخدام طائرات شاهد المسيره ومن المحتمل
ان يكون الهدف من وراء ذلك سينزاف شعبنا
وانظمه الدفاع عن الجويه وقطاع الطاقه
لدينا نحن نتصرف ونفعل كل ما بوسعنا
لافشالهم من تحقيق اهدافهم
حديثي ياتي بعدما نفذت اوكرانيا ضربه قالت
انها قتلت مئات الجنود الروس في منطقه
دومباز وفي اعتراف نادر للغايه قالت روسيا
ان الهجوم اسفر عن مقتل 63
لم يتم التحقق منهما لكن
المعلق الموالي لروسيا قال ان المئات
قتلوا وجرحوا رغم ان العدد الدقيقه غير
معروف بسبب العدد الكبير الذي لا يزال
مفقودا وقال ان المبنى نفسه دمر بالكامل
تقريبا واضاف على تليجرام ان الضحايا
كانوا في الاساس من القوات التي تم
التعبئتها اي من المجندين الجدد وليس من
اولئك الذين اختاروا القتال وقال ايضا ان
الاخيره كانت مخزنه في المبنى نفسه الذي
كان فيه الجنود ما زادت
هو مدونه
من روسيا عندما احتلوا اجزاء كبير من
الشرق اوكرانيا عام 2014
تع- 17
ورغم موقفه المتشدد ضد ياف الى انه ينتقد
بانتظام القياده العسكريه الروسيه
وتكتيكاتها لم يكن امام موسكو خيار سوى
الاعتراف بالخسائر في صفوف جنودها ولو ان
العدد يختلف كليا عما طرحه موالها ينتقدوا
العديد من المشرعين الروس القياده
العسكريه ومنهم سر جيمي رونالدو الرئيس
السابق لمجلس الشيوخ الروسي الذي قال انه
من الواضح انه لا المخابرات ولا الدفاع
الجوي يعملان بشكل صحيح لقد كان هجوما
مميتا او قاع اكبر عدد من القتل اعترفت به
موسكو في حادثه واحده منذ بدا الحرب يقول
مدون عسكري
[موسيقى]
ومع مرور الايام الثقيله للحرب تكتسب
القوات الاوكرانيه مهارات جديده وكبيره في
الدفاع ضد الطائرات الروسيه بدون طيار
اسقطت كيف جميع الطائرات بدون طيار البالغ
عددها 39 طائره امس وفق ما افادت به صحيفه
نيويورك
منذ بدايه العام وعدد طائرات بدون طيار
الايرانيه التي اسقطت فوق اوكرانيا تجاوز
بالفعل 80 طائره اطلقت روسيا امس سربا
كبيرا من الطائرات المسيره الايرانيه على
اهداف المدنيه داخل اوكرانيا قال سلاح
الجو الاوكراني ان اي منها لم يمر وافقت
جميعها ببنادق مضاده للطائرات وصواريخ ارض
جو وطائرات حربيه عشرون طائره منها اسقطت
فوق كياف وحدها وبحسب الصحيفه الامريكيه
فانه يكون احد اسباب نجاح احتياف ضد حمله
الطائرات المسيره الروسيه قرار واشنطن في
اوائل نوفمبر الماضي تزويد اوكرانيا بنظام
صاروخي ارض جو متقدم يعرف باسمز تحدثنا
كثيرا عن ساند في 360 ونذكر بانه يشمل
رادارا واجهزه استشعار وقذفات ومركز قياده
متنقلا ووفقا لمركز الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه وامن المعلومات وهو وكاله
حكوميه اوكرانيه لعب نظام الصواريخ
الامريكيه دورا في صد هجوم امس وقال
المركز على تويتر رغم تعلمنا تشغيلها قبل
اسابيع قليله فقط استخدمها جيشنا تقريبا
كان المدفعيه واعاده تحميلها باسرع ما
يمكن الاستخدام الناجح للغايه لهذه
الاسلحه يظهر ان جنودنا يتعلمون بسرعه لكن
مسكت تخطط لشيء اكبر من المسيرات في حرب
يبدو انها او ان نهايتها ستطول اذ قال
الفريق السابق قائد الطيران بعيد المدى في
القوات الجويه والفضائيه الروسيه ان
الطائرات الحامله للصواريخ الاستراتيجيه
ست تشارك في منطقه العمليات العسكريه
الخاصه في 20 23 الفريق كوبيلاس اضاف انه
سيتم تركيزه خلال تدريب الطيارين خلال
العام الحالي على تحسين مهارات استخدام
الاسلحه وانظمه القياده والتوجيه الاليه
مشيرا الى ان الط احنا الشباب المتدربين
بشكل جيد تلقوا الخبره القتاليه للمره
الاولى تصريح يثير تساؤل كبيرا هل تنفدت
موسكو سلاح جوها التقليديه لتلجا للقاذفات
بعيده المدى